as most of you already know we were
unable to report yesterday the secretary
released a report informing the general
public that
not our counties had reported as
necessary so that we can compare records
and ensure that there are no duplicate
votes in the provisional ballots that
we're prepared to set forth now
we ended up with an outstanding count of
1502 cures
that were not cured in the system we
have received the information that we
needed
from the secretary in the past 20
minutes and so we began our process
so at some point this afternoon we will
be rolling out our final unofficial
report to the secretary and making our
final
this weekend we will do the work of
reconciling and preparing for the canvas
on monday
tomorrow there will be no press
conference so this is the last one
again this afternoon we will be rolling
out our final unofficial uh
and begin reconciling so that we'll be
prepared for monday
any questions yes
sorry um so 1502 1502 were not cured in
the system yesterday so
the 16 000 provisional ballots deal with
the waiting for
oh absolutely yes we could not report um
i don't know if you've seen the
secretary's statement
but not all counties were able to report
yesterday and so we can't move forward
until we've confirmed all of our records
against all 16 counties
that report has been received in the
past 20 minutes so we've begun our work
and sometime this afternoon we'll have
our final unofficial
yes
they weren't ready to report and so did
not submit their provisional accounts
uh and individuals so there was we
couldn't complete our
our confirmation that there were no
double votes in other counties so we
couldn't
we couldn't move forward we had to make
sure that we were able to report against
all 16 counties
is there a reason why i can't tell you i
don't i can tell you the clark county
was ready
but we couldn't move forward without
reports from all 16 counties and that's
the secretary's responsibility to gather
that information
in terms of the provisional ballots can
you see where we stand
with that we're ready we've got the
information we need we're going to begin
getting them into the system
again sometime this afternoon we'll have
our final unofficial report and we were
ready last night
with that entered do you expect they
will have all everything decided in
terms of all the poll questions and
all of the last two races that were
still very tight
that this is it there's nothing else to
enter into the system so after this
final report
that is what we expect to report on
canvas day
well i provided that information quite a
while ago as far as the breakdown but i
don't have the final
count numbers yet i will be able to
report that after the canvas if
anybody's interested in that information
and you mentioned the calendar is 3 34
from this day which is 20 minutes ago
just from now 20 minutes that's always
good that's correct
yes 1500 cures that's it
on those no the deadline is over
yesterday at 5 pm was the
deadline for anybody to cure so those
will remain outstanding 1
500 too and you mentioned about
that you only received the report 20
minutes ago which means like 60 000
provisional balance
none of uh in process to target or
because you're waiting for that report
right we've got it 20 minutes ago we
received it so we're working on getting
them in and sometime this afternoon i
will have our final unofficial report
yeah so my question is
now like the county hasn't started to
process the 60
congressional ballots well certainly we
did we've been doing that for days we
had to verify that those records on
which ones were eligible in our eyes
to be cast and which ones weren't but we
can't finish our work until we get the
report from the secretary
that they've verified that all 17
counties have matched the records and
there are no duplicates so our work was
done
yes going back to the cure ballots the
outstanding 1500 or so is it because
the voters did not contact the election
department to
verify the signature and that's why
they're outstanding yes
now that you've been through all this
process you guys made your deadlines
last night
your staff as you said you guys have
been working extremely hard
you know i mean what what do you think
after all this is done you know
how's your staff performed and you know
what uh what what
all you learned from this unique
election well we're not finished
and so i don't want to jinx us but
everything seems to be in place for us
to finish on time on monday
i think i've communicated on many in
many different press conferences
i'm very proud of my staff and what
they've done
i think the general public thinks that
we work two days a year
on election day and we do not we work
throughout the year to improve our
processes
to implement new laws to ensure that the
integrity of our process is in place and
improve for efficiency
we're well known for integrating it
technology
into most everything that we do so that
we can do things more efficient by
adding
mail ballots to all active registered
voters i don't know that there was a
county in the entire country
that dealt with it as well as we did i'm
very proud of their work and
they've worked long hours they're
definitely worthy of praise the general
public should appreciate not just my
staff
but the thousands of people who work the
polls dealing with the pandemic
thank you all i appreciate you being
here